A common question I get is about the difference
between orthodoxy and Catholicism.
Let's explore some of the key differences.
Both orthodoxy and Catholicism share a common history
and origin in Christianity.
However, they differ in terms of their structure,
theology, and worship practices.
Orthodox Christianity is a decentralized church,
meaning that each local church has autonomy
and there is no central authority.
On the other hand,
Catholicism has a hierarchical structure
with the Pope as the ultimate authority.
Another difference between the 2 is their approach
to theology.
Orthodoxy places a strong emphasis on tradition
and the Bible,
while Catholicism also recognizes
the authority of the Pope and the Magisterium.
Finally, there are some differences
in the way they practice their faith.
Orthodox worship tends to be more focused on liturgy
and the use of icons,
while Catholic
worship may include more devotional practices
like the Rosary.
In the end, there is no Orthodox and Catholic in heaven.
In god's eyes,
we are his children.
I hope this video helped.
May god bless you all.